[Musik]
gut jetzt geht es weiter
und zwar werden wir jetzt dem wünschen
betrogen kasten und dazu mädchen
[Musik]
wenn nämlich der methodik ist eine
sammlung eine amüsante freundin betrogen
und die serie frei sind und sie
einzusetzen und zwar um dieses aviva
china zu distanzieren
das konkret an auszuprobieren
dieses engagement und was jetzt damit
auf sicht also es gibt da jetzt ganz
verschieden und die methode kann
seltsamen haben und manchmal und ich
möchte jetzt so ein paar dieser methode
kann einfach vorstellen weil ich glaubte
dass die geradeaus oder sofern sich
weich sein können und verschiedene
stadien dieses prozesses zb das aktive
hier zu unterstützen haben sind jetzt
merke es kann auch während des toten zu
ehren der veranstaltung
ihre teilnehmer sind gar kein cent in
das berühmte mieter aktiv
dann können sie ganz bewusst sagen
sondern dem ccs-gesetz diese situation
teilnehmer sind nicht so aktiv sein zu
lassen sich jetzt der aktiven methode
und dann können sie dann im normalfall
in diesem programm ganz syrien
welche methode sich am besten dafür
geeignet
sie kennen alle der situation dass sie
eine frage des plenums stimmen und keine
antworten zurück es sei das klassische
dilemma eines jeden dozierende deines
lebens betont
frage sie haben sich da eine
interessante
legen sie wollen dafür dass sie tausend
und sie bekommen nicht zurück was machen
sie
und da gibt es jetzt eine methode die
heißt plötzlich jeder student wieder
studenten gibt es eine frage stellen ein
konzert mit das nicht gewertet
so erhält jeder gleichberechtigt
gelegenheit sein weiter zu kommunizieren
und einschnitte gruppen meinungsbild
also das ist eine möglichkeit des spa
gar nicht mehr spazieren wir haben ganz
große kenntnis so machen ins blitzlicht
und zwar diese reibung wie ich schon
sagte der mit dem az
und jetzt daraus erwächst zu machen und
dann würde das sagen und zwar nur einen
kompetenten eindruck gar nicht kurz
ausholen
deswegen ist auch etwas zu sagen sehr
gering
nur ein punkt ist bei jeder das was er
sagt dass er bei uns ist
das setzt allerdings voraus dass jeder
teil
beleidigend sind was zu machen oder auch
die idee haben
sie können zum beispiel blitzlicht nicht
bei der routine machen so ein blitzlicht
ist ihr für den anfang mit zb zum
aktivieren
wenn sie jetzt zum beispiel ein thema
haben ich bin jetzt im sommersemester im
seminar über formen des unmoralischen
dann würde ich es mir überlegen das
macht schon hervorragende konzepte also
aktivieren um ausrichten lebenslicht zur
folgende frage was ist für sie ohne jede
chance von marcel viel leichter und da
habe ich es zu lügen
okay die lüge dann kommt der nächste
satz dass man kann den wechsel sei
schlicht oder rassismus oder wasser oder
irgendwie oder also solche ganzen dinge
ist und damit können sie sehr gut kann
beim neuen team können sie ihre
studenten ganz also ohne viel hemmungen
und das geht von einem anderen leben es
jetzt wenn sich die situation haben dass
sie ein komplexes thema besprechen und
diskutieren wolle
eine rückfrage gestellt hat wird dies
komme ja was machen sie dann
haben sie ideen ich nehme jetzt mal weg
wir können diskutieren dann mache ich
zum beispiel eine methode die könnte zum
beispiel auch also lauten don't make up
die studenten sollen auf einem blatt
papier fragen was nämlich heute als
wichtigste erkenntnis mit ebenfalls fast
verein zu diesem thema
den studierenden ein blatt aus teilen
und die studierenden sollen damals sich
grant ist es verbindlich
eine andere möglichkeit hat mir auch
sehr gut gefällt so genannte moore habe
ich jetzt nicht auf dem foto das sie die
frage hier ist man noch zurückstellen
einfach nur ins plenum geben
sie lassen dann eine gruppe bilden
da können sie mal zwei und drei
studierende sich zusammenfinden wer sich
viele vorstellungen und an die kunden zu
gute
und dann soll man die zwei kommt er
jeden zwei gruppe sich in dieser sehr
schwierige frage weisungs games
antworten gedanken
es können auch die zeit fest zusammen
zwei minuten zeit
je nachdem wie viel zeit ich leben
könnte in anderen gewisses ergebnisse
vor
ich würde nie mehr anzurufen und zeit
geben für solche aktivitäten teilt sich
eine vision eigene diskussion ergeben
die abtreten und mit dem ein aktiver
nichts zu tun
das bemerkte ich meine selbst auch wenn
sie die studierenden zu viel zeit geben
dann gehören sie schon immer
jetzt wiederum dieses thema die
fußball-legende ich weiß ich was also
zwei bis fünf minuten steine am besten
geeignete zeit in simone kurze geben
sollen studiert sich einfach mal
überlegen was sie zu dieser sache zu
sagen und zu einem dialog
das führt dazu dass die etwas zu sagen
cr unter das fest wird alles ein
geschützter raum oder gehen sie ein
bisschen thema proxy mit jesus bisschen
herum und hörer immer so ein bisschen
ein wechsel erst ein bisschen locker und
schauen was sagt dies die sekunde
dass es um eine schaukel stadt dassow
und band geraten ist kostenlos zu ende
gekommen um den jetzt darüber was ganz
antrifft des kontinents samsung sowie
zwei kleine hunde ist nicht aber wenn es
zwei beteiligungen instanz ins zentrum
und dann sagen sie sorgen jetzt sammeln
wir jetzt geben wir das war sehr groß
ich gemeinsam durch wurden bedingt haben
das geht man jetzt in den komplett
inspiration
wer hatte jetzt etwas interessantes aus
dieser gruppe und dann werden sie sehen
dass wir mehr meldung kommen alles
gekommen wären wenn sie gleich erwartet
hätte dass sich studierende werden kann
heißt sie
sie senken die hemmschwelle sich zu
holen
und sie geben den studierenden etwas
mehr zeit diese faktoren bedingt und
zwar im dialog
meine erfahrung mit diesen
diskussionsgruppen paulus manker immer
schon
vielleicht immer noch ist das problem
das ich gar nicht weiß welche art welche
eben echte überleben soll
wenn ich jetzt total geschirr über das
thema und da versuche ich auch
konzessionen zu erarbeiten
das hat ein bisschen gefehlt vielleicht
ist es wichtig dass man nämlich sagt
melden oder wie oft welche weise aber
wenigstens vielleicht auf welche weise
sie im inhalt haben gut oder punkt also
wenn es eine schwierige frage ist die
man nicht die wohngeld gibt könnte man
den studien ohne hier sicher stehen und
gehen zum beispiel dass man sagt ihr
könnt jetzt fünf minuten zeit und wenn
ihr drüber diskutiert berücksichtigt
bitte diese vom achtet achtet auf diese
punkte dabei also ob man ihn zum 70
jährige stirbt wenn es zu kompliziert
wenn die punkte zu viele sind können sie
auch im platt vorbereitung zubereitung
zu bekommen blood tour
da steht am ende darauf die in dieser
momente phase berücksichtigt werden
können sich studierende lag daran
orientieren oder das ganze interview
das heißt der niere die stoffe sie kann
treten selbst zurück aber sie merken dem
sie selbst zurücktreten müssen sie sehr
viel investieren um diese zurückgetreten
sich leisten müssen
die zeiten so müssen schauen dass etwas
wichtiges mal jemand anderes leben zu
müssen
für unterhaltung also sie sehen neben
der sehr verstimmt und als tutor desto
mehr müssen sie eigentlich gerade
präsenz aber hatte auf eine ganz andere
weise der präsenz präsenz bedeutet und
nicht mit dem formel zu stehen und was
zu sagen was andere hören dass es
ebenfalls heute geringsten präsenz
bedeutung ist sie präsenz geben darin
gerade auch bestehende die ganze
geschichte zurück zu ziehen und die
studierenden aus der serie zu machen
glauben sie diese nicht dass sie hier
alles machen müssen sie sind nicht wie
derjenige diejenigen die hier eine show
abziehen müssen die reaktion auf
inklusion live gespielt sie dürfen nicht
gerne zurücknehmen und weniger ist mehr
die merck & co
von der studentin auch viel mehr wenn es
ihnen den raum überhaupt geben bedeutet
eben nicht aus dem raum heraus zu gehen
jetzt mal wörtlich gesprochen und die
studenten selbst überlassen zum raum
geben bedeutung des studiums ohne zu
installieren
dass er selbst im raum der arbeit das
ist dem raum als solchen studenten erst
mal gewusst hast dann müssen sie als
boxer investieren so eine mobile gruppe
hat sich ziemlich gut bewährt und es ist
auch meinen beliebteste methode weil sie
einfach recht einfach zu bewerkstelligen
ist
sie brauchen dann nicht in exter im
interview jetzt aber noch ein paar
andere methoden den zaun aufgestellt
springt spuren dass ich zurück und die
möchte ihnen kurz anspricht als wenn man
das plötzlich da macht gehabt kann ist
auch eine lieblings methode von mir weil
es unkompliziert
dann gibt es fische oder
podiumsdiskussionen
die ist für ein größeres ablehnung
geeignet und zwar diskutiert da jetzt
nicht nur zwei professionelle 4 bis 6
erfüllen die an im inneren kreis sitzend
und die übrigen studenten hören im außen
kreis zu
und dann kann jeder sich von den ost
kreisenden in den kreisen gegeben und
rotationen dass jedermann zu hören
denn jeder mal des konzertes habe ich
noch nie gemacht wo sich zu geben war
mir zwar aufwendig aber auch nicht
ausgeglichen
sie haben damit eben auch bewirkt dass
die leute nur sitzen sind bei der
bildung einer fisch blaugrana fisch
kugeln müssen die studierenden aufstehen
und sich neu probieren oder informieren
heißt sie müssen würde diese neue hält
sich positionieren
und gerade diese beispiele sich
positionieren vom diskutant zu zu räumen
ich setze mich bitte dich geben und ich
glaube dass diese doppelpack von
geistiger handel körperliche position
hilfreich sein kann eben die thematik
genauer zu durchdringen genau als
[Musik]
interaktive meinung ist auch eine eine
methode die ich sehr gerne verwendet
hier kann man jetzt alles dezent etwas
zu schreiben
und die studierte dann per zuruf liste
die nennen einfach etwas was auch damit
zu tun dass ich mich gestellt jetzt ins
zentrum dass das thema unternehmer und
gute lehre und lehre gezogen sie dir
einfach zu lassen derzeit einfach an der
us konzern zu gute lehre können zb
heißen musik zu ergebnis sich unsere
begeistert diese ganzen tag den wir
vorher gesammelt habe die kriterien
aufzusuchen vorne aufnehmen und sie
können eben auch und damit sehr gute
vorwissen aktivieren
also zeitung
sie haben eine gewisse aktivierungen und
verantwortlich sie aktiviert sie könnte
jetzt diese interaktive meint wird auch
so modifizieren dass kleine papier
kreation vorbereiten stichwort mit
honoratioren kopf wir sind sie das
ermuntert
odermatt ohne koffer ist zum koffer der
sieht aus als wären darin tausende von
geldscheinen und als würde da es
verboten ist respektiert es am montag
geben sich stifter und verschiedene
gegenstände befinden die sie taktisch
einsetzt zb papier karton formen muss
kapieren also kreise oder rechtecke
moscato farblich häufig auch
unterschieden dann verschiedene stifte
scheren oder kleber und alles mögliche
und mit solchen schildchen können sie
genommen und den teilnehmern
verschiedene griffe montieren lassen
damit die studierenden der die begriffe
selbst premier war der im krieg befinden
sich auch in diesem koffer und diese
tafel hier bis mäßig geben jedem
und jeder zeile kern vordringen und kind
kennen und zwar dort wo er das gesagt
dass sie ganz sein
hier wird
ihr sofort ist auch sehr viel flexibler
gestalten welches in schreibende mit der
band crash - das können sie mit den
moderatoren kopf machen und zu halten
ist nicht zu teuer
ich würde daran haben dass sich seine
mannschaft an der letzten wende die
möglichkeit gibt unternehmens so ein
köfferchen mit mir haben sie alle
möglichkeiten drin da können sie über
twitter aktiver agieren darf ihr haus
das ist ein bisschen wenig wechsel
verschiedenen rollen verteilt werden bis
sie nämlich mit dem fisch pro habe ich
auch nichts zu geben aber wir haben
nicht mal was neues machen können sein
wenn man ausprobieren kugellager dass es
auch so dass hier komplexe themen ihr
zerlegt werden als wieder größere
niederrhein stuhlkreis und innen sind
die experten und die zahlen dann das
wasser
diskutiert und ihre das kann man sehr
gut nutzen zu dokument ist der
anspruchsvolle musste dass sie sehr
ambitioniertes thema und findet neben
auch sehr selbstsicher wissenstransfer
statt also die finde ich ganz ganz gut
aber sie müssen schauen dass sie den
raum dafür haben das spiel dominieren
können
das müssen sie eben schon vorher
überlegen dann machen sie es auch so ein
tipp zwischendrin machen sie sich schon
frühzeitig vertraut mit dem raum in dem
scania tutorium endlich genau hammler
angst wir sind die lichtverhältnisse
sind im sommer scheint die sonne
und wo könnte ich den stuhlkreis machen
und wo könnte ich die leute sind auf
machen sie sich da am besten schon zum
plan und grundriss vielleicht sogar ist
gut ist das morgendliche übersicht haben
in der dann alles inhaltliches sich
prinzip moment mit einem thematischen
gesagt das ist ihm auch gut um ganz kurz
in kurzer zeit ganz portierte ergebnis
das sichern und ich kann man da noch
mehr sammeln diese momente und kann in
der nächsten sitzung darauf zu spielen
so jetzt möchte sie noch der hinweis auf
die hand
dix und diese app können sich kostenlos
herunterladen
entwickelt und das ist dann eine
didaktik schulen loks großen tasche das
ist dieser wünsche mittels kasten
interaktive mobile und diese interaktive
digitale methoden kasten team dazu dass
eben praktisch nicht angesichts ihrer
spezifischen situationen ergebnis
forderung im senegal sich eine
maßgeschneiderte methode in der wehren
lassen können die sich dann helfen
können ich zeige dass man das spiel also
zu sehen sie dann ist es richtig heraus
und das zum beispiel die feedback gibt
es dann also verschiedene karten also
sozial form abeba phase das ist also
praktisch die letzte aviva phase wo es
wäre natürlich für diese phase ist diese
methode bezeichnet
und da können sie dir einfach eingeben
können sich die anzeigen lassen
gesprochenes sehen und sagen bis hier
also diese app bietet ihnen seien ganz
flexibel
die methoden sich wieder situationen
gerade am besten geeignet ist können sie
mal schauen wie können sie auch die
gruppengröße haben geben denkbar dass
die kuppel ist und 18.000 wie viel zeit
sie verwenden wollen für diese methode
ich würde sagen nicht zu filetieren
kommt heraus auch zeugen mehrere ob die
teilnehmer zusammen setzen und homogen
des und ergebnis orientiertem tabu
qualität bezieht sich sowohl auf
wissensstand also das haben wir am
anfang gemacht haben zur haltestelle
homogenität wieder und kann aber auch
bedeuten dass wir nur weibliche
teilnehmer im moment liche also das kann
man das geschichte drinnen wo man das
für nicht sofort meine der inhalte
erfolgt wird nun weiter weil er von
daytona
ich habe meinen veranstaltungen sehr
viele senioren studenten und wenn man
dann gewisse übung macht könnte es ein
paar probleme gegeben hat das also
ältere semester dann nicht mehr so
flexibel unter umständen sind zumindest
schon zu machen
also achten sie auf diese zwei faktoren
bei die jetzt an sagt also wissensstand
und halte jeder teilnehmer und da auch
eine wissens der methoden angemessen zu
ergeben
und diese ganzen parameter die
prozentsätze ihrer teil
die können sie hier diese app eingeben
und dann künstlich anhand dieser
parameter eine maßgeschneiderte getötet
generieren können
also das ist die didaktik toolbox für
die hosentasche
darauf wollte ich sehen
hin verlassen ja das war es jetzt
eigentlich überhaupt hier sehen sie noch
ein bisschen die genaue beschreibung von
einer methode also die ablauf der
feedback from ablaufe beschrieb sie
stellen ihre feedback frage betont dass
jeder nur kurz dazu stellung nehmen
damit es wirklich ein konzert geben sie
einen eingestellten kurzzeit becker mit
denen sie als bombe aus geben die sich
also zum beispiel fast viele machen was
ich gar nicht schlecht für das würde ich
so nicht sagen ist unbekannt
diese wird es ist wahr dass jeder dabei
ist hier ist der erste und mit irgendwie
so ein händler
wenn einfach symbolisch
auch nicht dass es damit eine andere
idee ist noch was machen machen sie
nämlich so kleine welt nicht zu haben
wenn es keine richtige bombe wird und
welche weichen stellen und die werfen
sie den leuten von denen sie wollen dazu
beitragen das kann man zum beispiel
unter dem teilen können
das blitzlicht zu machen dass man sich
das immer zu hören also derselbe gewesen
und würde dann den ball zum wechsel
teilnehmer sind es muss nicht die lebens
zu sein und sagst hast du willst und so
wandert der wahl das ist alles eine
veranstaltung das denken danke mehr
bildlich und dynamisch beweglichem raum
sichtbar
aber die diskussion zu zeigen bildlich
nachgezahlt durch den verlauf des tages
zeigen sie offen auch wenn es auf den
ersten blick ein bisschen kindisch und
wird seine tore
das ist nicht nur irgendwie was an am
zelt sammelstellen des ganztägigen gut
sind aktuell zum auflockern und markt
seite dadurch experimentierfreudig was
sollten einsatz solcher mittel ja das
war es von diesem kaputt und wir machen
jetzt in der un gremien diskutiert über
und zwar produziert
diese beschuldigungen konkreten
anwendungen aus dem situationen des
lebens